explique-moi tu es libre d'aller où tu
veux
dans une autre temporalité
un autre univers
alors pourquoi rester dans celui-ci et
te battre pour le sauver
parce que dans cet univers ma mère est
vivante
[Musique]
je veux pas la perdre encore une fois
le temps a une trame
et la revit compulsivement
des gens différents des mondes
différents
ça tire comme
baisé aimant
[Musique]
c'est mon visage tu m'as volé mon visage
si tu décidais d'aller dans le passé
tu n'imagines pas les conséquences que
ça pourrait avoir
Bruce je pourrais tout arranger tu
risquerais surtout de tout détruire non
c'est pas possible
complètement briser l'univers
nous attendions
j'ai créé un monde sans méta-humain
il y a plus personne pour nous défendre
besoin d'aide
[Musique]
je suis Batman
si je peux pas défaire ce que j'ai fait
si je peux pas rentrer
on est même pas sûr qu'il y aura un
avenir
c'est quoi le plan Batman on fait quoi
on essaie
c'est pas Clark je m'appelle Kara
Paris tu fais quoi là c'est pour nos
enfants ils seront contents